dark psychic forces dominated our
national political debate over the past
two days as 20 Democrat wannabe
presidents took the stage in Detroit to
humiliate themselves we will examine the
best of the worst with a special
emphasis on breakout star marianne
williamson
then the mailbag all that and more i'm
michael knowles and this is the michael
knowles show mary anne baby she is the
break out star of these debates we'll go
through everything we'll give you the
50,000 foot view we'll we'll get into
why Mary Ann broke out I also want to do
a little bit of a deeper dive into who
she is and what she's peddling because
we love her she we're members of The Orb
gang we're we've left the yang gang now
we're on the Mary Ann orb gang but she's
also peddling ideas that are extremely
destructive and not just political ideas
but also cultural and spiritual ideas so
again to that all in a second I want to
point out though that marianne
williamson made the single truest
statement during either night of the
democratic debate the single true
statement she said three things in this
statement one democrats are idiots to
focus on wonkiness they're idiots to
focus on the accounting details of their
various zillion dollar plans that the
americans don't care about that at all
was the first thing she said that there
is a dark psychic force that we are
fighting against in politics that is
completely true and she said that if
democrats don't change their strategy
soon the donald trump is going to be
reelected so much truth packed into just
28 seconds here's a listen do you think
any of this wonkiness is going to deal
with this dark psychic force of the
collectivized hatred that this president
is bringing up in this country then I'm
afraid that the Democrats are going to
see some very dark days we need to say
it like it is
it's bigger than flint it's all over
this country it's particularly people of
color it's particularly people who do
not have the money to fight back and if
the Democrats don't start saying it the
but those people feel that they're there
for us and if those people don't see
Donald Trump will win as things stand
now truer words have never been said all
three points are totally right wonkiness
is stupid and the Democrats you'll
notice their debates have been all about
these very particular aspects of their
different zillion dollar programs they
all take for granted that we should take
over one-sixth of the American economy
with health care they all basically take
for granted that they should force their
huge federal health care programs on all
of America so they're just arguing about
the details this is what the left does
the left has the vision of the anointed
as Thomas Sol would say the left has
this utopian progressive vision they see
utopia they see the perfect place they
don't realize that utopia means no place
they think it means the perfect place so
they see it and they're progressing
toward it and it doesn't even dawn on
them that some people might object to
their utopia doesn't even dawn on them
hmm maybe the federal government
shouldn't control one-sixth of their
economy and all of our health care
decisions and life and death maybe
that's not such a great idea they don't
they don't think that way they just they
just assume that we're all on board with
this progressive plan even though poll
after poll shows that progressivism is a
minority viewpoint in America so study
after study shows progressivism is is
about 20% of America may about 40% of
America's conservative the rest would
call themselves centrist or moderate or
undecided or independent and yet they
are certain that that 20% of America
which is progressive represents the
whole of the country so they're not
discussing ideas what you will hear in a
Republican debate it's much more than in
left-wing debates is a discussion of
different ideas different visions of the
country you've got a little bit of that
last night especially with Tulsi Gabbard
we'll get to that at the end but you for
the most of the debate you did not get
that and what the American people want
from their presidential candidates is
big ideas President Trump didn't get
into the minutia in the details of every
policy proposal he probably didn't read
the minutiae in the details of every
policy proposal he talked in Bay
ideas we're not electing an accountant
we're not electing the functionary at
the Department of so-and-so some
mid-level bureaucrat we're electing the
president we want big ideas we want a
big vision Mary Ann totally got that
also the dark psychic force she's
completely right about that when people
made fun of her that was the viral
moment dark psychic force is very real
yeah I forget who said it a lot of
people have been credited with saying at
bottom all political differences or
theological differences st. Andrew
Breitbart the patron of Hollywood
conservatives said politics is
downstream of culture and culture we
know is downstream of religion cult and
culture come from the same root what a
culture worships defines that culture so
when we're talking about political
problems it's not just some someone lost
their health insurance because of this
aspect of a federal program and if you
fix that aspect then you're okay
it's not just we need to lower the
marginal tax rate 0.2% you're talking
about spiritual realities because human
beings are not just meat we're not just
animals we don't just grunt along and
eat our slop and fall asleep in our own
filth
well increasingly in America we do do
that but we're not supposed to do that
well Winston Churchill said when great
forces are on the move in the world we
learn that we're spirits not animals the
destiny of man is not measured by
material computation Ronald Reagan knew
that he quoted that very line in his
breakout political speech a time for
choosing we have a major spiritual
component to our humanity that is that
is what matters to us are these
spiritual things and Mary Ann is talking
about that and and when she talks about
a dark psychic force and we're talking
about what we all know to be true which
is that mankind is broken were fallen
and the origins story of our whole human
nature of our of our whole fallen world
is that the devil tempted man in the
Garden of Eden and we made that choice
and gave in to that temptation and we
got kicked out of paradise and now we
live in this broken world because sin
and death pervaded the world that dark
psychic force it as always is crouching
trying to devour you that's the devil
and the devil exists Antonin Scalia used
to laugh about this because in a secular
world people think you're crazy
if you
believe in the devil and what Antonin
Scalia answered in a New York magazine
interview he said you know I believe in
the devil and the interviewer who's some
secular girl who worked for New York mag
well it must be awful scary to believe
in the devil and he said you're looking
at me like like I'm crazy do you realize
how out of touch you are with most of
America do you realize how out of touch
you are with the vast vast majority of
people who have ever lived who have
believed in the devil and then this was
the key line he said many more
intelligent people than you or I have
believed in the devil and Marianne
Williamson is basically saying that
exact same thing and people are calling
her crazy for him but she's totally
right about that and then she's right
the Trump will win if the Democrats
don't change but there is a big problem
with Marianne Williamson we'll get to
that in one second first we need to
thank our sponsors over at Wesley
Financial Group you know someone who has
done this or you have done this yourself
and if it's you I'm sorry to hear it
someone who bought all those lies from
the timeshare companies and threw your
money into a timeshare and now you can't
get that money at it is just bleeding
you dry this is what they tell you Oh
timeshare is a great investment
timeshare it's all gonna be a legacy for
your kids you can stay wherever you want
whenever you want guess what it's all
alive it's all a total lie the ugly
truth is with a timeshare you can never
tell how much it's actually going to
cost or when it's going to end that is
totally up to the timeshare company and
you are just a piggy bank for them many
owners trying to sell their time shares
online find out the hard way that it is
not an investment when they can't get a
single dollar for it those with rising
annual maintenance and assessment fees
buying a timeshare is like giving the
timeshare company a blank check that's
all it is it is just a total scam and
when you die guess what your family gets
stuck with this burden stop the insanity
today there is a way out if you are
stuck in a timeshare nightmare fix it
today don't waste a single extra dollar
go to I cancel timeshare dot-com tell
them that I sent you to make sure you
got to tell them that I sent you this is
very important go to Wesley financial
they will get you out of your timeshare
permanently or you pay nothing to get
your free information kit
telling you all about how it works go to
I cancel timeshare dot-com that is I
cancel timeshare dot-com go over there
nav don't waste another penny on those
scams so Marian says the truest
statement of the entire democratic
debate of either night but there's
something very wrong with with Mary Ann
so she's the new Andrew yang we like
that
Andrew yang is broke marianne williamson
is woke that war gang is the new woke
thing but they're calling it the orb
gang why because orbs and crystals and
opal and all these sort of things are
symbols of the New Age movement and
that's what marianne williamson is
marianne williamson is a guru
self-styled guru promoted by oprah a
million times written a bunch of books
about a spiritual and religious movement
called the New Age movement most people
don't know what that means so I it's
it's certainly worth taking a moment to
explain it because marianne williamson
is a fun sideshow i love her i only
tuned into the debates for her she's
also peddling a dangerous heresy that
almost certainly comes from the devil
himself i'm not joking about that i mean
this is like a genuinely diabolical
heresy that she is promoting so she's
been promoted by oprah that's how you
know she's probably peddling diabolical
heresy so oprah has promoted this woman
for years and oprah herself is another
peddler of the New Age movement nonsense
so Oprah does something called super
soul Sunday think about the cojones it
takes to style yourself as that kind of
religious leader when you're not a
religious leader super soul Sunday as
though Oprah is this expert on the human
soul she's made herself into not just a
TV figure not a political figure not
even just a cultural figure she's made
herself into a religious figure as has
Mary Ann and the question is what
religion is Oprah she's not Christian
occasionally she said she's sort of
Christian but she doesn't believe in
Christian orthodoxy or anything even
remotely
resembling Christian orthodoxy so she's
not a Christian religious figure she's
not a priest she's not a pastor not a
deacon not a bishop she's not Jewish
right she's not a Jewish religious
figure she's not Hindu she's not Muslim
she's new-age and she did an interview
on Superbowl super soul Sunday with
Marianne Williamson starts out sort of
okay
just like all new AG stuff does and then
it gets real kooky real fast finish
these sentences okay
the world needs love love I believe in
God
love is everywhere I am grateful for my
daughter and my work do I get to yes
whatever you want what is the soul for
me it's the truth of who we are the
light the love which is within us it
goes by different names but the truth of
us Michelangelo said when he got a
statue that he would go to the quarry
and get a big piece of marble and the
way he imagined it God had already
created the statue and his job was just
to get rid of the excess marble so
that's what we're like inside is the
being that God has already created some
call it the Christ the Buddha mind the
Shekinah the light the soul and our job
is to get rid of this excess useless
fear thought-forms of the world that
actually hide the light of the soul
excuse me sorry I just had to take a few
puffs there to try to get on the level
with Oprah and Mary Ann so you see that
kind of defining feature is this total
relativism and this total
self-centeredness so she goes yeah man
some people call it Christ some people
call it Buddha some people but you know
it's just it's really what it is it's
not just that radical relativism it's
all about you you are that light you are
that truth you are the way
the truth and the life and the Buddha
and the Christ that is new age and it is
wickedly wrong where does she get these
ideas from because as I think some
people think she's just kind of spouting
nonsense obviously she is but she's not
just spouting nonsense she's spouting a
very specific kind of nonsense from the
New Age movement specifically from a
book called a Course in Miracles don't
take my word for it she tells Oprah on a
whole other program about her love of
this particular book you have a morning
ritual marianne williamson i love to I
love orange juice I love a cup of coffee
go back into my bed I make it neat I
bring up my Course in Miracles I do my
meditation you must have done it a
hundred times by now
she had done it more than a hundred
times even there's another clip of Mary
Ann on Oprah years and years ago where
she's asked point-blank what's your
favorite book favorite books of course
in miracles' what is a Course in
Miracles
a Course in Miracles is the new-age anti
gospel I wouldn't you wouldn't call it a
gospel but it's the anti gospel it's
written by a tortured woman named Helen
Schucman and she channeled what she
called a new gospel through a spirit
claiming to be Jesus Christ
so this woman this very troubled woman
Helen had a vision and she believed that
Jesus was speaking to her she believed
that a spirit from the spiritual world
who was claiming to be Jesus and
speaking to her a new gospel she was
having this private revelation of a new
gospel and why was the Spirit speaking
to her the Spirit who she said was Jesus
was speaking to her to correct errors in
Scripture and the teachings of the
church now Christians hold the Bible to
be inerrant the scripture to be without
error right she is saying no no it not
only is it full of error but Jesus
himself spoke personally to me and only
me to correct these errors specifically
the errors that the Apostles lied so we
can't trust the Apostles anymore
raises the question why can we trust
Helen if we can't trust any of the
Apostle so actually Newton followed
Jesus and to whom Jesus said I give you
the keys to the kingdom of heaven
spirit claiming to be jesus also told
Helen that we are all Christ and that we
have no need of a savior so this is this
is not just a heresy this is not just a
different version of Christianity this
is anti Christianity this is the
opposite of Christianity and Helen was a
Columbia University professor in
psychologist and she was an acquaintance
of a priest named father Benedict J
Russell and father Grusha l-- that was
close enough to her that he actually
gave a eulogy at her funeral so it's not
like he was some opponent of hers they
actually seemed to be quite friendly he
later said having known this woman and
having given the eulogy at her funeral
quote this woman who had written so
eloquently that suffering really did not
exist spent the last two years of her
life in the blackest psychotic
depression I have ever witnessed and I
know people who have gotten involved in
the New Age movement
New Age is no joke and it does lead
people to some pretty dark places oh the
reason this matters particularly for our
politics is not just that we're pretty
soon gonna be all living under the
Williamson administration but it's also
because New Age ISM is the kind of
defining spiritual movement of our
culture it's radically relativistic we
live in a very relativistic culture we
have your truth and my truth you can't
tell me man that's just your opinion we
live in a culture that denies physical
realities that very much the case of the
New Age movement draws on a lot of a lot
of older heresies that say that the
physical world is basically terrible
that I have nothing to do with my body
that I am just I'm merely my soul in my
spirit the New Age movement denies the
reality of suffering they say this whole
world is an illusion this whole world of
suffering that we have is just an
illusion forget about it it's not real
and it denies the fall of man it denies
the brokenness of human nature it says
we don't need a Savior we're all our own
saviors and we're gonna save ourselves
that's certainly what we all believe in
this culture I mean that's what so many
of the leftist movements are about
self-help pride even recycling even in
environmentalism we are saving ourselves
we are the change we
waiting for we are going to cause the
sea levels to stop rising as Barack
Obama said we are our own hope as Barack
Obama said to what this movement is is a
gnostic heresy but Gnostic dualism I
guess you would be the technical term or
theosophy is another one of these
technical terms we'll get into what that
means in a second that is a defining
feature of our culture you know where
you see it most clearly instead of just
trying to define all these terms I'll
give an example an example of this is
transgenderism so like Gnostic dualism
would be this idea that there is this
hidden secret knowledge and the dualism
would be the the total difference
between my soul and my body
traditionally what we believe what
Christians believe is that our soul in
our body are are unified we we are
neither simply our soul and we're not
simply our bodies we're human beings and
human beings have body and soul and then
lots of various other ideas tell us
we're either one or we're simply the
other so materialism tells us we're only
our body and Gnosticism tells us we're
only our soul in transgenderism you see
a little bit of each of these right
transgenderism tells us if I am a man I
am by all visible evidence a man but I I
think really deeply that I am a woman
then really I am a woman right that's
its denying the physical reality for the
metaphysical reality or with the
so-called spiritual reality same thing
that comes directly out of New Age ISM
or you you see the you see the kind of
schizophrenic other side of it on our
culture too which is that we deny
spiritual realities altogether sex is
just sex sex is nothing it's just two
bodies smacking together two people
bumping uglies in a dark room abortion
is not killing a human being it's not
ending a human life now it's just it's
like getting your appendix taken out the
baby isn't a baby it's just the product
of pregnancy it's just a clump of cells
right a clump of cells well I'm a clump
of cells too by that same logic
all my body is is just a clump of cells
but we know that the clump of cells when
it's a human being has more than that we
know that human beings have a spiritual
component too so our culture wants to do
what wants to sort of have have their
cake and eat it too wants to say in the
one hand physical reality is totally
meaningless and if a man wants to be a
woman than he really is a woman but on
the other hand the culture denies
spiritual reality all together and says
human beings are nothing more than a
clump of cells and the New Age movement
is responsible really I guess for for
both of that both sides of that cultural
craziness and that's why marianne
williamson
is the most fun candidate she is
speaking plainly she's speaking in Big
Ideas she's speaking to a spiritual
dimension that makes her automatically
so much more interesting than the rest
of those Schmucks on that stage for the
last two night the only trouble with
Marianne my only hesitation with getting
on the orb gang is that she is peddling
diabolical heresy and one of the
problems with just making jokes about
Marianne all the time and even
acknowledging some of the interesting
intuitions that she has about politics
is people lose sight of the seductive
and false and misery inducing
spirituality that she is embracing so
you see so we talked about this for all
the other candidates we say their
policies induce misery socialism makes
misery happened in the Soviet Union
happened in China happened in Mena's
whele happened in North Korea happened
everywhere socialism has been tried it
breeds human misery those are misery
making policies the thing that makes
Marianne a little different is she's not
even really talking about policies she
was asked about her health care plan and
she basically said yeah I kind of agree
with everybody the left and the right
but what she is peddling is a misery
making spirituality and unfortunately
it's a spirituality that became very
popular in the 70s 80s 90s I think it's
kind of on the wane a little bit now but
a lot of people have gotten caught up in
it people like Oprah have been peddling
it to to housewives and middle-aged
women who sip wine on Tuesday afternoons
for a very long time and it's just a
it's just a bad idea so we should speak
clearly about about the real dangers of
Mary
Williamson we must embrace the memes as
funny as they are with caution we must
proceed with caution so how do the other
candidates do who are living on this
plane of existence rather than on
whatever plane marianne williamson is
living on Joe Biden had the worst night
of all I mean he just got clobbered he
got clobbered by the other candidates
who all of whom were going after him we
expected that but what's really worse
for him much more devastating for his
campaign he clobbered himself right so
he's still the front-runner
everyone's going after him and he just
flailed around here is the most frequent
line that you heard from Joe Biden all
night
my times up my times up my times up
anyway anyway my times Joe Biden would
be making this impassioned point he'd be
responding to some criticism he'd be
doing an okay job a little meandering
and then he just ran out of steam and
this happened at the last debate - he'd
go and you'd say and I believe this and
you're lying about this and we achieved
anyway my time's up you've got to stick
the landing buddy but he just ran out of
words he ran out of ideas he ran out of
energy couldn't finish his attacks he
seemed very dull and unfocused and he
kept getting attacked for the Obama
legacy which was one of the more
interesting aspects of this campaign
pretty much everyone was attacking
Barack Obama and this shows you the
trick of leftism so here is john delaney
who is a totally forgettable candidate
you don't need to remember his name but
here's john delaney arguing with Bernie
Sanders about their health care plans
well I'm right about this we can create
a universal health care system to give
everyone basic health care for free and
I have a proposal to do it but we don't
have to go around and be the party of
subtraction and telling half the country
who has private health insurance that
their health insurance is illegal so you
remember when Obamacare was gonna be
universal health care remember that that
was it once and for all we're gonna have
Obamacare now they're all as sailing
Barack Obama to hear them talk about
Barack Obama during this debate I
thought gosh we got to find this Obama
guy get him to run as a Republican
this Obama guy sounds like the most
conservative guy
ever heard of because this is what the
left does the the March leftward never
stops it's never enough
so Obamacare that's nothing now we need
the real one this is gonna be the real
universal health care and then guess
what in ten years five years we're gonna
need another the real universal health
care they're just gonna keep taking more
and more and more because here's that
here's the secret I'll let you in on the
trick
there cannot be universal health care in
a free country if people can still opt
out of it so if the government can't
force you to buy a product that you
don't want then there's not going to be
universal health care because some
people are gonna say I just don't want
to pay for them that is what the aim is
the end here is government control most
Americans like their current health care
they don't want brand-new totally
different health care and so the
government is going to have to come in
and force people and that's what this is
all a mentored so they're all going
after Obama Joe Biden I think could have
survived that he can't survive his own
delirium I don't know senility or he
just was really foggy and hazy and out
of it here's the word at the end of the
night Joe Biden couldn't even tell the
difference between a URL web address and
a text message he told people to go to
Joe 303 301 ever that is if you agree
with me go to Joe 303 305 thank you very
much that was he's referring to a text
message he meant to say text Joe to the
number 303 301 else had been saying go
to our campaign website so he said go to
he didn't know the difference between a
text message and a website because Joe
is about a hundred years old and neither
very stable nor a genius so that wasn't
even the worst part of it he got another
number wrong in his closing statement he
said that four more years of donald
trump basically would be fine okay
that's all we have left but eight more
years would be a disaster so if donald
trump got rid of the 22nd amendment and
ran for
Herman got a third term that would be
bad but anything short of that would be
just fine
four more years of Donald Trump will go
down as an aberration hard to overcome
the damage he's done but we can overcome
it
eight more years of Donald Trump will
change America in a fundamental way
America we know will no longer exist
shows you how smart President Trump was
to label him sleepy Joe we all thought
it should be creepy Joe or lying Joe a
plagiarist Joe or whatever sleepy Joe
sleepy Joe is the key here because he's
actually losing it he's actually not
that sharp so I think he's still the
front-runner he's still leading the pack
but I think over time you're gonna see
those numbers slowly drop if other
candidates are able to rise up brings
you to who Leon Castro is the former
Secretary of HUD he has absolutely no
business running for president he seems
more like a an SNL cast member playing a
presidential candidate than an actual
presidential candidate he had one great
moment though last night where he
accidentally exposed another major flaw
of leftism so he described how his
grandmother had diabetes and how she was
on Medicare and how her diabetes kept
getting worse and that's why everyone
needs Medicare this is something very
personal for all Americans you know I
grew up with a grandmother that had
diabetes and I watched as her condition
got worse and worse that whole time she
had Medicare I want to strengthen
Medicare for the people who were on it
and then expand it to anybody who wants
it so that doesn't make a whole lot of
sense does it she had diabetes she was
on Medicare kept getting worse and worse
and worse that's why you will need
Medicare not a great argument but this
is what the left does there's a problem
then the left creates a government
program then the government program
either doesn't help or makes things
worse and then they say see this is
evidence that we need more of that same
government program I mean he's kind of a
nothing character who Leon Castro when
he announced that he was running for
president I happened to be on a TV show
they said Michael what's your reaction
Huli on Castro announced he's running
for president I said I had a ham and
cheese omelet for breakfast both of
those are equally consequential
for the 2020 presidential election ,
lares came in with a lot of momentum
because she shanked Joe Biden at the
last debate everyone was rooting for
Kamala you know among the kind of anti
Biden crowd Kamala had a really tough
night because Tulsi came out and
clobbered her campaign listen to how
Tulsi does it you took issue with
senator Harris confronting Vice
President Biden at the last debate you
called it a quote false accusation that
Joe Biden is a racist
what's your response I want to bring the
conversation back to the broken criminal
justice system that is
disproportionately negatively impacting
black and brown people all across this
country today now senator Harris says
she's proud of her record as a
prosecutor and that she'll be a
prosecutor president but I'm deeply
concerned about this record so I love
what she does here just from a tactical
standpoint she's asked a question she
completely ignores it she then
acknowledges that she's going to ignore
it and she goes in for the kill on
Kamala this was a masterful attack and
here's how she finishes off the attack
there are too many examples to cite but
she put over 1,500 people in jail for
marijuana violations and then laughed
about it when she was asked if she ever
smoked marijuana she blocked evidence
that would have freed an innocent man
from death row until the courts forced
her to do so she kept people in prison
beyond their sentences to use them as
cheap labor for the state of California
and she fought to keep the system in
place that impacts poor people in the
worst kind of way absolutely devastating
just brutal so the new meme that's going
around is that Camila is a cop commonly
Harris is a cop and it's just like
little kids getting arrested and calm
alone laughing and you know people being
sent to prison and she's laughing this
doesn't need to hurt Kamala Harris but
the way it is playing out it currently
is hurting her so the reason it's
hurting her is because she keeps
flip-flopping Kamala Harris on the one
hand says that she's not gonna abolish
private health insurance then she says
she is gonna abolish private health
insurance and she says she doesn't want
reparations and she doesn't want
reparations she's trying to have two
sides of every political issue I think
this is because she's hired a lot of
Hillary Clinton's old campaign staff not
a great idea one of the worst run
campaigns in history you probably don't
want to hire her old staffers so she's
also flip-flopped on her biography and
when she started running she refused to
acknowledge that she was a prosecutor
which is her whole career right she
graduated law school she's a prosecutor
she then becomes the Attorney General so
she's the top prosecutor then she's in
the Senate for five minutes now she's
running for president her whole career
is as a prosecutor and yet she wanted to
run away from that because Democrats
hate law enforcement right now they
don't want to run on law enforcement so
she she's just become nothing then she
started to embrace the prosecutor angle
so she said I'm gonna prosecute the case
against Donald Trump I think this is the
smart play you can't run away from
yourself all you have to run on is who
you are if you're gonna run on being
someone else they're gonna just vote for
someone else you got a run on who you
are and so if she's smart and if her
campaign is smart she's going to start
running on this prosecutor thing again
own it and go after Tulsi Gabbard
because the best defense is a good
offense by the way I mean if the Harris
campaign is watching just remember even
though the left wing of the Democratic
Party is now very anti law-enforcement
cops are the third most trusted
institution in the country according to
a number of polls that have come out the
only more trusted institutions are the
military and small-business cops are a
good play Democrats are running against
all of this popular stuff they're
running on the Lea spot they're running
on reparations 29% of Americans support
it two-thirds of Americans oppose it
they're running on open borders
immigration enforcement is the number
one chief political issue in the country
according to a Gallup poll that came out
just two weeks ago and yet they're
running on open borders very unpopular
they're running on a free health care
for illegal aliens very unpopular
they're running on all of this stupid
stuff they're they're running on taking
health care away from 150 million people
they're running against the American
flag bad idea very unpopular why why are
they doing this the party knows this is
a bad idea
the party knows at the party that's why
they opened the debate with the
presentation of colors and a major star
spangled banner singing they just know
it doesn't play well in Peoria when all
these left-wing candidates are spitting
on the flag but the candidates
themselves are just wrapped up in this
leftism because they have nothing real
to argue about in the current political
climate they have not but it if they're
just going to oppose Trump then they
have nothing real to argue about if
they're just going to oppose Trump the
economy is going well unemployment is
very low we have relative peace abroad
things are just going well and so they
have to argue about these fantasies and
this this opens up the Democrats to a
lot of vulnerabilities the Democrat
fantasy breaks through they say that
they're representing all black people
they're representing all racial
minorities they held that debate in
Detroit one of I think the single
blackest city in America just as a
percentage of population it was the
whitest audience I've ever seen there
were no black people on the stage the
first night two black people on the
stage the second night that's out of 20
candidates I counted like two or three
black people in the whole audience only
Democrats could fill an audience in
Detroit with basically only white people
the only
black people we saw really where the
people performing the national anthem on
this stage it's just that fantasy of
Democrats there's one really important
aspect of this debate there's one really
healthy thing going on in this debate
which we'll get to in a second then
we'll get to the mailbag but first I've
got a second bite of Facebook in YouTube
go to daily wire.com you get me you get
the Andrew Clavin show you at the ben
shapiro show you get the matt walsh show
you get to ask questions in the mailbag
which will be coming up you get
everything and you get the leftist
here's tumblr you get the you get the
leftist years tumblr for when the orb
gang and marianne williamson becomes the
nominee you get the leftist years tumblr
for when tulsi gabbard shanks Kamala
Harris on stage and Joe Biden can't
remember his own name you need the
leftist years tumblr or you will drown
watching the remaining 10 Democratic
presidential primary debates go to daily
wire.com we'll be right back with a lot
more
there is one really healthy thing going
on in this Democratic presidential
primary which is you are seeing
something that started with the
Republicans in 2016 and it's continuing
now in 2020 you're seeing the beginnings
of a political realignment
so you're seeing old orthodoxies
political orthodoxy being smashed old
ideological certitudes being destroyed
and this was obviously more apparent in
the Republican primary in 2016 but
you're seeing it particularly with Tulsi
Gabbard in 2020 here is Tulsi Gabbard
making an argument on trade that sounds
a whole lot like Donald Trump's argument
on trade which sounds a whole lot
different from the old Republican
argument on trade and hers is a whole
lot different from the current
Democratic argument on trade here she is
for fair trade not trade deals that give
away the sovereignty of the American
people and our country that give away
American jobs and that threaten our
environment these are the three main
issues with that massive trade deal
the trans-pacific partnership I think
the central one was the fact that it
gave away our sovereignty to a panel of
international corporations whose rulings
would supersede any domestic law that we
would pass either a federal law or a
state or a local law this is extremely
dangerous and goes against the very
values that we have as a country what to
speak of the fact that it would have a
negative impact on domestic jobs and
that it lacked clear protections for our
environment these are the things that we
have to keep at the forefront as we look
to enact fair trade deals with other
countries to make sure that we continue
to be a thriving part of our global
economy this is a highly conservative
argument that she just I mean look she
use the word sovereignty all the other
candidates on stage we're talking about
open borders we don't even have a right
to decide who comes into the country and
Tulsi starts talking about sovereignty
and she's talking about it particularly
on trade and conservatives with a short
memory get this wrong we have this idea
that conservatism demands total free
trade free trade is conservatism
directly speaking that isn't true that's
been true for the last four decades or
so that the left has been ante free
trade and the right has been Pro free
trade but that's only been true for a
few decades traditionally speaking the
right is anti free trade that the GOP
was actually founded against free trade
it was the protectionist party Abraham
Lincoln the first Republican president
said give me a protective tariff and
I'll give you the greatest nation on
earth
free trade became what you would call
the neoliberal consensus beginning
during the Reagan era continuing through
the bushes and through Bill Clinton -
and this was a consensus among both
parties now we're dealing with some of
the political consequences of that there
were many advantages that came through
that sort of global free trade and there
were some negative consequences as well
and what we're debating now with Tulsi
Gabbard is bringing up is a really
healthy discussion which is you'll hear
some people the real free trade at all
at all costs can't even possibly
question it what they'll say is free
trade works and the other one doesn't
work well economics doesn't doesn't make
moral arguments economics is a social
science just as this does that talks
about efficiency but when we're talking
about politics we're talking about moral
arguments not just what the policies do
but what the policies should do what
policies we should enact and what Tulsi
is is bringing up is basically who cares
about an efficient policy to increase
even if it does increase GDP by some
percentage if you lose your national
sovereignty in the process who cares
about it if you lose protections for
some of your workers in the process you
lose if people lose their jobs and they
get addicted on opioids and they kill
themselves
who cares about increasing GDP slightly
or having more efficient markets if you
lose your environment your natural
environment these are debates that cut
across that what we would call the left
in the right of the last 30 or 40 years
now she could be making that argument in
a GOP debate maybe she could or maybe
she should rather Trump basically did
make that argument that that's very
healthy
now we only left a little bit of time
for the mailbag unfortunately maybe
we'll try to have a few more mailbag
questions tomorrow we've had an issue on
the website a little bit of a tech
glitch so I didn't get any mailbag
question since after I think July 25th
if you sent in any mailbag questions
after that put them on my Twitter right
now I have a thread going on Twitter you
can add those questions we'll try to get
to a few more tomorrow as well if we
have time but let's get through the ones
that we have now while we can from
Margot what happened to the stylish
Maddow glasses also happy 400th episode
thank you for a happy 400th I can't
believe it's been that long and Ben
hasn't thrown me out the window yet as
for the Maddow glasses I just kept
getting mistaken for that MSNBC host and
I couldn't take it anymore so I took the
glasses off but I'll put a poll up on
Twitter I want to know your opinion
should I embrace my inner Matt honest
and put the glasses back on
or should I remain in my slightly more
masculine slightly more conservative
aesthetic and keep the glasses off I'll
put the question up on Twitter after the
show from Daniel what are your opinions
on the two trillion dollar an hour
minimum wage well I think it makes just
about as much sense as a 15 or 20 dollar
an hour minimum wage you make a great
point which is that if I if I could ask
the candidates one question all of the
Democratic candidates I would ask them
do you support a thirty dollar per hour
minimum wage maybe I'd make it even
you've got to find the right line you
don't want it to seem ridiculous but you
want to get the point across maybe I'd
say do you support a $40 an hour minimum
wage and they would have to either say
yes because the logic of their current
argument is if you have a minimum wage
that basically just creates money to
fall out of the sky or they would have
to if they were sort of sane and wanted
to reach sane people they would have to
explain why a 30 or $40 an hour minimum
wage doesn't make any sense the trouble
with that is the same reasons why a 30
or $40 an hour minimum wage don't make
sense apply to a 15 or 20 dollar an hour
minimum wage which is there's no such
thing as a min
wage the only real minimum wage is zero
you are not entitled to a job real
minimum wage is zero and when you raise
the minimum wage too high when you when
you're really when you raise it at all
then you raise the cost of labour you
you then make it more likely that
someone will invest in capital and you
reduce the labor force for any
particular business it's not like
raising the minimum wage all of a sudden
gives businesses 20% more money to spend
on labour they just they have the same
amount of money so they can pay either
more people or fewer people or they can
buy more robots to do more of the jobs
that the people were doing that would be
the question that I would ask them and
I'd be curious to hear their thoughts on
that 2 trillion dollar minimum wage from
Charles in the absence of a divine power
or prior consent from the child prior to
conception is conception not immoral
does this not mean that we are either
immoral as a society or must accept that
God gives us permission to procreate I
think the the problem that you're coming
up against is you're elevating consent
as the most important if not the sole
moral category which is what our culture
does right now that's what the left does
they say everything is perfectly moral
as long as you consent you can do
whatever you want do whatever you want
with your body do whatever you want with
each other as long as everybody consents
then it's moral but that isn't true I
can do plenty of immoral things by
consent if I you know it's like Fifty
Shades of Grey
if a man smacks his wife around but they
consent to it does that make it right to
smack your wife around no of course not
it's still quite wrong consent is
insufficient and this gets to a broader
problem that the libertarian right and
the left have embraced which is that
they put consent at the basis of their
politics everything I enter society by
my free consent otherwise I'd be living
in the woods somewhere I engage in a
social contract that was John Locke's
idea but these are these are wrong ideas
they don't exist we don't in the state
of nature we're not living as Adams in
the world all on our own
ality that that is just a false premise
in politics consent is not the key duty
is the key responsibility is the key
loyalty is the key affection and love
are the key I don't own my life in the
sense that I didn't create my life I'm
not responsible for the creation of my
life I have to thank my parents for that
they have to thank their parents and
ultimately we have to thank our Heavenly
parent I owe something to my parents I
owe them respect I owe them some loyalty
I owe them love that's something I'm
born into the world with I never
consented to that obligation but I owe
it to them anyway when you switch your
politics from a politics of consent to a
politics of duty from a politics of
rights and entitlement to a politics of
affection duty loyalty responsibility
and respect the world starts to make a
whole lot more sense take one more
question
Aaron is it ok for Christians to visit
and pray at non-christian spiritual
sites Buddhist temples for example I
have visited plenty of spiritual sites
of other religions I visited temples in
Varanasi India Hindu temples I've
obviously been to different Protestant
denominations and Jewish denominations
things like that Jewish temples rather I
think it's fine to visit those things as
a sort of cultural or historic curiosity
to expand your knowledge but you should
not attend those worship services I
think it's perfectly fine when you're
walking past a temple in India to say a
prayer to Jesus but I wouldn't attend
those spiritual services I think that's
that's probably a bad idea
yeah I don't think you should say well
I'm really curious about this other
religious service so I'm gonna go and
participate in that I think that would
be sinful I don't think that's ok at all
now now we're about to see the extreme
of that in politics because Marianne
Williamson is about to just cast orbs
and crystals all over all of the culture
and so I guess when you watch a
Democratic presidential debate in a
certain sense you are participating in
another religious service so you've got
to be careful about that but
I think that's the difference if you are
learning about something if you're
studying something in a scholarly or
academic way that's one thing if you
were actually participating in it I
think there you're gonna run into a
little spiritual trouble that's our show
we'll try to get to more mailbag
questions today because I feel like I
cheated you all by talking too long
about 2020 and the Democratic debates so
we'll get to a little bit more tomorrow
if you haven't checked it out and you
haven't been able to submit a question
go do it on Twitter in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Knowles show I'll
see you tomorrow for a rare Friday show
see you then
my times up my times up the Michael
Noel's show is produced by Rebecca dabka
wits and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austen Stevens
edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is mixed by
Dylan case hair and makeup is by Jeshua
alvera and our production assistant is
Nick Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is
a daily wire production copyright day
Lee Weyer 2019 hey everyone its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
well the second round of the second
Democrat debate is over and our choice
is clear are we going to stick with me
mean mr. Donald Trump who has restored
the economy kept the peace and restore
the Constitution too or are we going to
go with a nice compassionate
good-hearted Democrat will destroy
everything we'll talk about it on the
Andrew Klavan show I'm Andrew Clavin